un acuerdo sin compromiso político así
calificó el presidente de eeuu joe biden
al anuncio que hizo de que su país
comprará y donará otras 500 millones de
dosis de la vacuna contra el cob y 19
elaborada por facer con ello la casa
blanca estaría duplicando su donación de
fármacos y espera que otras naciones se
sumen para disminuir el impacto de la
pandemia
sabemos que para vencer a la pandemia
aquí tenemos que vencerla en todas
partes mantengo la promesa de que eeuu
se convertirá en el arsenal de vacunas
como fuimos el arsenal de la democracia
durante la segunda guerra mundial work
show pero será suficiente un documento
de la ong amnistía internacional señala
las principales farmacéuticas como
responsables de la desigualdad y la
escasez selectiva de vacunas al dirigir
gran parte de su producción a los países
ricos están sumiendo a algunas zonas de
latinoamérica áfrica y asia en nuevas
crisis llevando hacia el límite absoluto
a los debilitados sistemas de salud y
causando semanalmente decenas de muertes
evitables de acuerdo con datos de
working data casi seis mil millones de
dosis han sido aplicadas en el mundo con
más del 43% de la población ha recibido
al menos una dosis y el 2% de ellas en
países de bajos ingresos en eeuu the
casi 390 millones de dosis aplicadas
solamente un 10% las recibió la
población afrodescendiente